i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle a federal district judge in tampa
has vacated biden's cdc national mass
mandate for planes and other modes of
public transportation we're going to
have more on this monumental ruling i'm
ruling for freedom in just a bit
but for now
sayonara sucker we begin tonight with
the old debate trap that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now imagine asking nick saban
to tolerate a game
where all the referees are known to hate
the alabama football team now in fact
these referees have made public
statements saying how much they despise
the crimson tide
well that's pretty much been the
situation with republican presidential
candidates and the moderators chosen by
the commission on presidential debates
and after years of conservatives urging
the rnc saying please cut ties with this
ridiculous organization on friday it
finally did chairwoman ronna mcdaniel
said in a statement we are going to find
newer better debate platforms to ensure
that future nominees are not forced to
go through the biased cpd in order to
make the case to the american people
now the gnashing of teeth that you can
imagine that followed was predictable
this is a big deal another blow to our
democracy it's also a virtual guarantee
that america will retreat further into
its partisan echo chamber once the
republican party decided that the
american free press is bad that
journalism is something they can not
only do without but that they are
against as a party
well yeah this is where that ends
no rach they're not against journalists
but they are against playing in rigged
games
it was not a spontaneous demonstration
is that what you're saying please
proceed governor
by i want to make sure we get that for
the record because it took the president
14 days before he called the attack in
benghazi an act of terror get the
transcript it he did in fact sir so let
me let me call it an actor can
he did
call it an act of terror
give me the transcript candy and then
there's the time one of those unbiased
moderators began a primary debate with
personal questions your ex-wife gave an
interview to abc news in another
interview with the washington post in it
she says that you came to her in 1999 at
a time when you were having an affair
she says you asked her sir to enter into
an open marriage would you like to take
some time to respond to that
no
but i
i
will
i think the destructive vicious
negative nature
of much of the news media makes it
harder to govern this country harder to
attract decent people to run for public
office and i am appalled that you would
begin a presidential debate
on a topic like that
john had to adjust his depends there
that moment then there's the time cnbc
turned cnn hack john harwood played his
preferred role of dem operative
mr trump yes
you've done very well in this campaign
so far
by promising to build a wall and make
another country pay for it right and
make americans better off because your
greatness would replace the stupidity
and incompetence of others that's right
let's be honest
is this a comic book version of a
presidential campaign
even the guys over at c-span weren't
immune and went to great lengths to
cover up their bias
steve scully was caught seeking advice
from the mooch remember that who would
become a never trumper when his direct
message was mistakenly put out as a
tweet
of course trump called him out and he
ended up being right now i could go on
and on but why bother we all know that
these so-called journalists
well we know how they feel about
conservatives and as you can see from
the way they treated old romney and
gingrich and santorum so many others
this isn't limited to trump
the notion that democracy somehow
requires that conservative candidates
submit to horribly biased questioning
every four years that is ludicrous
unless democracy of course was
meaningless back in 1858 when lincoln
faced off against douglas in one of the
most storied debates in u.s political
history with no moderators and no
panelists
i'd say the american people learned a
lot more just by reading exactly what
the candidates said back then
now the modern day candidate confab
didn't really begin till 1960 when for
the first time in history the debate
between two major presidential
candidates back then john f kennedy and
nixon was televised
remember people who listened on the
radio thought that nixon had won but on
camera it was the opposite kennedy
looked really cool and polished nixon
looked kind of sweaty and a little bit
shifty
now after that there was a debate lol
for 16 years
it picked back up in 1976 but by 2012 it
was beyond obvious that the moderators
were dead sent against whoever the
republicans nominated
obama was their lord and savior and he
had to be venerated and protected at all
costs
the bias then worsened over the next few
presidential cycles in 2016 the
commentariat hated trump so much
that there were serious demands by
supposedly respected media figures
that the press had a duty not to be
objective when covering trump
you cannot cover trump the way that you
would cover a normal person because he
is not a normal person the trump
presidency has changed the way
we cover news we have been trying to
treat uh donald trump's presidency as if
it's normal trying to normalize what
can't be normalized
well there's not been a single moderator
from the fr past i think three election
cycles except maybe of course from fox
who viewers wouldn't wholeheartedly
believe supported the democratic party
not to say otherwise looking at these
fools laughable the press shouldn't
complain though they have only
themselves to blame
had they actually made the effort to
call balls and strikes to report the
truth about the results of both democrat
and republican policies on domestic and
foreign affairs then most americans
would consider the debates important to
preserve exciting tough but fair both
sides
look at just the last few years
look what the press did they sold the
phony russian collusion narrative they
buried hunter's laptop they silenced
those who actually reported on it
then they pushed the destructive
lockdowns and vilified those who
questioned the lockdowns
they touted universal masking even of
little kids
they sided with blm at the same time
covered for violent antifa and
anti-government protesters and of course
can't forget this they obsessed
endlessly over january 6th
and then they downplayed inflation
and come on they're still covering for
china we know that even when they're
starving china is tens of millions of
their own people
so unfortunately as we've seen in so
many other areas of american life
the media lost its prestige and
credibility long ago
just like the public health sector has
lost the respect of a huge segment of
the american people
just like the courts just like the
prosecutors just like the intel agencies
even the pentagon
they've all become hyper partisan
but remember they're supposed to work
for us
but too often
it seems like they're working against us
and the ideals that made our country
great
for many years the gop was run by the
bushes and the cheneys and those folks
have proven over and over that they
would rather lose to the democrats than
actually do what the republican voters
want
so i think they were kind of happy to
live with a biased press corps because
they hated their own voters more than
they feared the left
even romney who was treated horribly in
2012 you just saw that clip
he was happy to go down quietly rather
than rock the bipartisan establishment
boat
but my friends those days are over
republicans have new leaders now leaders
who actually think we're right and that
giving power to the hard left is bad for
america
so the gop is finally finally beginning
to stand up for itself
and the country as a result will be
better off
and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else